a musical welcome for Pope Francis in
front of this Cathedral in the capital
asuncion to round off the second day of
the pontiff's visit to Paraguay
sar-e-aam is yoga tomorrow has been
practicing and playing for the Pope for
many months and it was very moving I had
goosebumps when I saw him right there in
front of us there you hit the ball
before holding mass in the cathedral
Francis met with environmental activists
and heads of Paraguay's indigenous
population it was a clear gesture of
solidarity with the country's
disadvantaged minority his message was
the same as on earlier stops on this
tour political leaders around the world
must develop a new economic model to
help the poor people's lives must no
longer be sacrificed on the altar of
wealth and profitability the pontiff
also urged an end to corruption like
what obscure corruption is the plague
it's the gangrene of society for example
no politician can do his job if he is
being bribed by people who are corrupt
give me this give me this power give me
that or I will do this to you what I did
once this happens in all the places in
the world because that is how it is if a
country really wants to preserve its
dignity it must yank it out oh do you
see that in da way love them all on
Sunday a final open air mass in Asuncion
will hail the end of Pope Francis's
week-long visit to South America